before women were taking online quizzes
about whether their a carry or Samantha
they were asking themselves a Maya Jo or
an Amy before there was Edward versus
Jacob there was Lauri versus professor
bear and over the more than 150 years
since Little Women was originally
published there have been thousands of
adaptations feature films television
adaptations plays ballets operas and at
least two animes based on the original
novel so despite being written off as
proto chiclet or Kitty lit or as Alcott
herself once put it moral PAP for the
young little women has worked its way
into the consciousness of readers for
the last 150 years and has stayed there
but what is it about the tale of the
March sisters that keeps us coming back
for those of you who haven't read the
book or seen one of these many
adaptations Little Women
written by Louisa May Alcott and
published in two parts between 1868 and
1869 is the story of the four March
sisters Meg Jo Beth and Amy the novel
follows their trials and tribulations
growing up in Concord Massachusetts
during the Civil War while their father
is off serving as a chaplain in the
Union Army they are brought up by their
austere and wise mother or Marmee and
are taught all sorts of empowering
lessons about being kind charitable
intelligent and loving in the face of
hardship the token boy of their world is
their rich half-italian orphan friend
Laurie who is our romantic MacGuffin for
the novel now in terms of plot the book
is less story driven and more of a
series of character vignettes exploring
the lives of the titular little women as
they leave behind childhood and enter
adulthood giving away their Christmas
breakfast jo cutting off her hair for
money
Amy burning Jo's manuscripts with his
scar generations of young female writers
forever Laurie's proposal to Jo and her
rejecting him and Laurie just eventually
settling for Amy
oh yeah and Beth dies spoiler alert I
guess now you might think that all this
mundane Cinda mental and moral lesson
rearing was the kind of work that Alcott
was used to writing but if you take a
look at how the novel came to be you
find that little women was actually is
somewhat outside of her wheelhouse in
September of 1867 publisher Thomas Niles
wrote to Alcott to ask if she would
write a book specifically targeted to
young girls
but she wasn't initially wild about the
idea said Alcott never liked girls or
knew many except my sisters but our
career plays and experiences may prove
interesting though I doubt it
ouch however in spite of her initial
animosity towards the idea
Alcott took the experiences of her life
and family and with some creative flair
turned them into what would become
Little Women according to an boy drew
Alcott used the book as an opportunity
to immortalize some of the aspects of
her life while concealing others Alcott
was herself the second of four sisters
the others being Abigail Mae Elizabeth
and Anna roughly and it became Meg
Abigail Mae became Aimee and Elizabeth
became Beth and also died and Jo was
basically a self insertive alka the
elcott patriarch Amos Bronson Alcott was
both a man very ahead of his time in
terms of abolition women's rights and
education while also being a fanatic who
put his principles ahead of his family's
well-being because he was a vegan before
anyone thought veganism was cool his
family wasn't allowed to eat meat or
wear anything other than linen in the
winter in Concord Massachusetts and he
only approved of vegetables that grow
upward so potatoes were out too
oh and he left his wife while she was
pregnant with their third child to go
stay in a room by the Pennsylvania
library so he could read maybe this
constant absence in his family's life is
why mr. March isn't around in the novel
although Alcott gives the fictional
father a more noble reason to be gone
thanks daddy a as the scholar Judith
federally writes much of the popularity
of little women then and now derives
from its embodiment of the cultural
fantasy of the happy family which the
Alcott's both were and were not the
Alcott sisters like the Marx sisters had
real artistic ambitions the sister who
who meg is based on had dreams of being
an actress just as Louisa had dreamed of
becoming a famous author and may a
famous artist and with Joe Alcott stand
in the shared dream to be a famous
writer blurs the lines between reality
and fiction Alcott wrote primarily as a
means to provide for her family
according to rue writing could never be
a purely artistic affair there was room
in the Alcott family for only one
self-absorbed genius thanks
ei Alcott would get between 50 and $75
for each of her stories which was pretty
Bank for back in the day she actually
preferred to write her revenge and saucy
stuff under the pen name am bernard to
keep the Alcott brand consistent while
Jo at first writes saucy violent short
stories out of general love at the game
she ends up doing it because it makes
money and because she has yet to write
her real masterpiece her in-universe
novel also titled Little Women
Alcott successfully negotiated with her
publishers so that she kept the
copyright for Little Women which they
caved on with little pressure because
they didn't think it would end up being
the gangbuster that it was part ones
initial printing sold out so quickly
that the company who published it
Roberts Brothers had trouble keeping up
with demand and it's never been out of
print since and Little Women wasn't just
a hit with well little women as a
contemporary of Alcott's wrote brave
merchants and lawyers meeting on their
way downtown in the morning said to each
other
have you read Little Women fufufu and
laughed as they said it but more
noteworthy than its commercial success
was what little women brought to the
table on the literary side of things
according to rue what Alcott brought to
children's and American literature was
the fresh language of American
colloquialism and a precursor to the
even more vulgar speech of the
lower-class Huck Finn who would appear
16 years later in 1884 in terms of
writing what made Alcott's work so
noticeable was the way it so
realistically captured the slang and
vulgarity of everyday life without wordy
purple prose but if the book allowed
Alcott to comfortably provide for her
family it also meant that she had to
deal with fans
according to route their letters poured
in with demands to know what would
happen to the four March girls or most
importantly whom they would marry as if
that was the only end and aim of a
woman's life the author grumbled once
the second volume was published a lot of
fans and critics both back then and
today took real issue with Joe giving up
her career to be married but that wasn't
where Alcott had originally intended to
take the character it was a narrative
choice made at the encouragement of
Alcott's publishers Alcott wanted Joe to
be an unmarried successful writer but
that idea was a little too revolutionary
for the 1860s as the scholar and Douglas
has noted Alcott could not disregard
however the unpleasant facts
fronting her female contemporaries and
characters unlike her male peers a
Victorian woman rarely had a spouse a
family and a full-time career so Jo
under pressure from the publisher had to
have a husband and not a career so who
does she marry no one doesn't marry
either of them no but if Jo is going to
have a happy ending
it was going to be in terms that felt
real alcott much like Rian Johnson
didn't believe in giving in to
fanservice
despite the readers wishes Alcott
refused to pair Jo up with Lori her
dreamboat neighbor with enough money to
solve all of her family's problems
denying 19th century readers their
ultimate OTP so she gave Jo her very old
creepy old guy I mean older German
professor and the film adaptations have
been trying to figure out how to make
that work for over a hundred years newer
versions deal with it by making him
either hot and or younger so even though
the publisher wanted the picture of mid
19th century womanhood filtered through
a certain lens Alcott's personal life is
heavily infused into the final product
and that sense of realness is a part of
what has made it so enduring Douglas has
called these sisters the only mythic
American characters from the Victorian
era unashamedly believably actively
capable of love friendship loyalty and
sheer fun Rou adds that little women was
a cultural phenomenon that knew no
boundaries of age gender or class let's
unpack that it is interesting to think
that a book about for sis hetero white
women has managed to be so universally
loved from the queer readings of Jo to
the race bed adaptations or books
inspired by Little Women it is clear
that there is something that connects
women across the board with this novel
it's more than just a book about a group
of sisters coming of age and getting
married and perhaps it's that the March
sisters have the relative freedom to be
themselves and feel cherished despite
society's constraints they feel human
and tangible with their virtues and
vices while also having the full ability
to experience girlhood for a lot of
marginalized people the girl hood of Meg
Jo Beth and Amy may not be relatable but
it is as idyllic fantastic and magic
as the idea of getting a letter from
Hogwarts for Alcott the cozy world of
the Marches was somewhat distant from
her own life of poverty abolition and
frustration but there's always a need to
return to a place of innocence and
freedom regardless of if it is something
he'd experienced or not as times change
we find new ways to express the
universal elements in little women and
I'll let you finish Louisa May Alcott
was raised to believe that she could be
anything she wanted to be but there were
no limits in what women can do in spite
of real world limitations
despite her initial concerns that comes
through on the page Little Women isn't
important because it's realistic or a
perfect mirror of our world it is
important because it inspired
generations of women to be whole human
beings and that is worth revisiting
although you know maybe throw in some
adaptations of Zora Neale Hurston Toni
Morrison Amy Tannen Isabella L Dante in
there for some seasoning to each other
Little Women and laughter I was a good
take you're about to get story